we have no idea what threats are out
there
we can't do this alone
we need you
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie we got a
whole bunch of new Captain Marvel and
Avengers for to break down they just
released a prequel story that's more of
an Avengers 4 story than it is a Captain
Marvel story but their branding at
Captain Marvel because it's all about
introducing her character the upside of
that being it gives us some more clues
about when they're gonna drop the
Avengers 4 trailer so just a whole bunch
of stuff to break down we'll do a new
giveaway for IMAX gift certificates all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a Marvel related
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this the prequel
story revolves mostly around what's
going on with Nick Fury in the events
leading up to infinity war the snap and
him setting off that super advanced
space pager to get Captain Marvel's ass
back to earth so they follow the events
of the last couple of big Avengers
movies in their conflicts including
Civil War through Nick Fury's
perspective as he's talking to Maria
hill and they're sort of gauging
everything from behind the scenes
keeping tabs on the really big plans and
the reasons why they bring the Avengers
together like you get a teaser for that
at the beginning and they use it as a
tagline when they were marketing
infinity war bringing together a group
of remarkable people to see if we could
be something more as they move into the
Civil War period you see Nick Fury's
perspective which we did not get like he
just showed up at the end of infinity
war like he's been doing a whole bunch
of stuff and we have no idea what so
while he's watching all this footage of
the Avengers going to town and each
other at the big airport battle he says
to Maria Hill the Accords might be handy
for keeping tabs on enhanced individuals
in the field but regulating them seems
like a bit of a political pipe dream
plus I don't see Thor signing on the
dotted line if he ever shows up again
remember the whole reason why Thor left
was to investigate his visions that he
had there's actually a deleted scene for
that all included in an upcoming video
but Maria Hill and Nick Fury just talked
about what's going to happen when they
need the Avengers to come back together
because they're sensing some bigger
cosmic threat down the road then as Nick
Fury gets ready to take off to try and
track down Captain America he says it's
true that they're a group of remarkable
people more than I could have hoped for
in a team all the good they've done I
still need them to be something more so
that's obviously teeing up Avengers for
like them becoming that something more
that was originally promised Maria hill
playing the cynic says I've heard
something about heroes never meet them
they'll only let you
down in the Nick Fury sort of teeing up
Captain Marvel says not all of them she
says you got one you haven't called yet
might be helpful to have a back-up plan
in case the worst should ever come he
responds by saying not if we do our job
right we'll never be in a position of
having to call her make sure you keep an
eye on the raft I got a feeling our guys
are gonna need a little assist in
kicking the door open just another way
of letting you know that Nick Fury and
Maria Hill helped Captain America bust
everybody out of the raft at the end of
civil war so it wasn't him doing all
that stuff by himself so while all the
dust from civil war in the sokovia cords
are still settling Nick Fury goes off
the grid officially months later we pick
up with Captain America's Secret
Avengers trying to track down a bunch of
[ __ ] our East olan weapons on the black
market Nick Fury comes to help out clean
up Captain America is kind of surprised
that he's there like what are you doing
here normally we talk through
intermediaries so even though he hasn't
been talking to Iron Man during this
period it does let you know that he's
been talking to other Avengers
associated people like Nick Fury he
tries to explain to him that something
big is coming and cap is just like look
I gave Tony a phone if he needs me he
can call me so was just the cap side of
that Iron Man scene when he was in the
sanctum trying to explain when he pulled
the flip phone out why he is not talking
to captain america still pre infinity
war you go back to the Avengers based
Tony's testing out his new bleeding-edge
armor trying to see its response time so
he just has Friday blast him with energy
weapons it has the suit deploy
immediately so you have to imagine him
walking around with his new arc reactor
in the nano housing so even if he didn't
tell it to activate and he like I kicked
out of a window or something it would
activate and save him a lot of this is
just set up for his battle on Titan with
Thanos like he tests out all the energy
weapons it works great let's test
structural integrity this is just a
reference to Thanos throwing the moon at
him but you have to imagine that these
things are striking him with the force
that Thanos was striking him with Maria
Hill does the same thing with iron man
that Nick Fury was doing with Captain
America trying to get tabs on them
getting them to bridge the gap like look
we need to make this all water under the
bridge the Avengers need to come back
together they also have a funny joke
about her working for him at one point
remember after a Winter Soldier at her
shield collapsed she was looking for a
new job and she went to Stark Industries
so for a brief period it seemed like she
did work for him he references Captain
America's flip phone
he picks it up and looks at it briefly
then comments about vision turning his
transponder off which they paid off
during infinity war it was when he was
spending time with Scarlet Witch because
this is still a West Side Story like
he's still a team Iron Man working for
the legit Avengers and then you have
Scarlet Witch that's with Captain
America's Secret Avengers so they were
sort of running off to spend time
together every once in a while then they
pick up in that post-credit scene where
they're driving through town and all of
a sudden they just sense everybody
starting to disappear so Nick Fury flips
out grabs the pager then disappears
himself after dropping that really big
f-bomb this is just part one there'll be
a part two coming sometime soon so I'll
do a breakdown of that as soon as it
drops but the really cool thing about
this prequel comic is that there was an
advertisement in the back for another
Avengers for prequel story that's gonna
release December 5th what is important
about that date if you guys don't
remember that is one week after the
infinity war trailer was released last
year and why would they market an
official Avengers for prequel story
before releasing the Avengers 4 trailer
so just big theory that we're gonna get
that trailer sometime around
Thanksgiving it could either be the week
of Thanksgiving or it could be the week
after right now I'm just tentatively
planning for Tuesday November 26 so
couple weeks away closer than you think
and of course I'll do a breakdown to
that prequel story but there's also
another new synopsis on the Japanese
Captain Marvel poster which is pretty
telling it gives you a much better idea
what the plot is about so the text on
the poster translates to lost past
memories trapped powers gained is this
me question mark the story before the
Avengers the reason why they probably
put the story before the Avengers on the
poster is just to remind you that this
is the setup they shall be in Avengers 4
they want to sort of market both films
at the same time like oh wow they have
this cool thing that's coming up and
it's gonna be a really big deal in
Avengers 4 so don't forget about that
movie - the idea that she has a lost
past and her memories have been trapped
also feeds into the idea of gas lighting
as it seems like they're teasing in the
movie like they won't tell you who Jude
Law's character is for a while we
thought he was playing Marvel the
original version of Captain Marvel there
are a lot of people that have thought
that he could be playing gone rogue
because what if she gets her powers I've
already done a video about the way the
they've changed her character and how
her powers work so I'll link that at the
end of this but imagine she gets her
powers in this accident here then for
some reason she has a bit of amnesia
what if Jude Law is there what if he
just gaslights her tells her that she's
part of Star Force and takes her back to
the Kree homeworld and she forgets all
about her life on earth and then he uses
this memory device to sort of mess with
her even more until she comes back to
Planet Earth chasing after the scrolls
runs into Nick Fury and whatever buried
memories that she has starts to surface
and she realizes what's been going on
this whole time like wait a minute
you've been gaslighting me for years now
and if you're not familiar with the term
gaslighting it just means you're
manipulating someone by psychological
means into questioning their own sanity
so imagine a version of events where
Jude Law is trying to get Captain Marvel
to question whether or not she actually
really did live on earth like no that's
not real they're lying to you you've
been Creed this whole time even though
we see her as a child on the beach here
on planet earth so just remember that
Marvel just changed her backstory they
simplified it quite a bit now her mother
is fully Kree
I already done a video about that so
I'll link it at the end of this but the
big reason for the change was is because
they didn't want it to feel like Green
Lantern where someone comes from outer
space gives her her powers and then she
goes off with them as sort of a backup
character it's a version of events that
they can use that will bypass the male
version of Captain Marvel if they chose
to do that they could still include him
in the movie in some way but unless
they're combining the Marvel character
with like the Y on Raw and that's who
Jude Law is he's either not in the movie
or Jude Law really is playing him and
he's the straight-up villain which would
also be a really huge retcon for him in
the comics and I don't know that they
would do that so he might just be lying
about who he is and he really is someone
else say like yawn Rob but important
things to remember we are now officially
on Avengers 4 trailer watch if we get
any more news about when that's gonna
drop officially I will totally do a
video about it no worries
congratulations Angelica Barbosa you're
the giveaway winner for my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here for my
Stan Lee tribute video and click here to
learn about Captain Marvel's brand-new
origin story in the Marvel
universe thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]